Husband has been struggling recently with twitches and his hands and feet sore spots around his joints and
In his feet he states his hands and feet go numb. It is muscles feel weak
And he's so tired all the time. Can this be related to endocrine issues or to neurology neurological?
He's a bit of a hypocrite
For example, let's say it just goes straight to thinking that she's dying
He's also suffering from really bad depression and anxiety and he's been taking an insid drug
Because of this for years now. I don't know what to do or how to help him anymore or what doctor to go see
But again, okay, here's a symptom. So the person's having twitches and his hands and feet
And he's an insid drug for depression and anxiety which
You know again, there's a person that depression and anxiety because they have a deficiency in a medication
You know, I don't think so so getting to the cause of this in the root cause of things is really the way to go
Unfortunately, it's just not our medical system today if you go if you probably went to a medical doctor at
60 years old with these symptoms
Most you know most likely you're just going to get a prescription of something
Which I don't think you have a problem because you have a deficiency in some sort of medication
Um, it's just the system that we live in and I don't know if there's really a way to fix that but find a doctor that doesn't practice that way
So yeah, you can contact our office and schedule a case review and we can certainly start working through some of the process of
I'm covering this because you got to start digging
So as far as the twitching and hands and feet one can cause twitching and hands and feet something as simple as um, you know
um
Mineral deficiency nutritional deficiency as we age many people are eating correctly
um, they can have
twitching in their hands and feet can be a neurological issue or would not say it's an endocrine issue
Um, it's either neurological or just functional nutritional issue
um, if it's bilateral twitching in the hands and feet um
It's it's probably more than likely a nutritional type thing we'd have to dig into it a little bit. So um
As far as the anxiety and and depression go you want to dig into that a little bit too um, certainly
inflammation is at a root cause of a lot of different issues
You could have inflammation in the gut that's causing inflammation of the brain that's causing these things
Certainly that would tie to the anxiety of depression
One of your you know a good video to watch is if you go on our website and you search
um in the search bar go to counters clinic.com search on the search bar neuro inflammation
I created a video
I think I talked about this a number of weeks back
But I made a video several years ago about neuro
Inflammation it's in brain inflammation
And it goes into detail you might have to watch the video a couple times because it goes into detail about your microglial cells in the brain
And what's called a glial private which is so so common
And when a person has
anxiety or depression that's your first sign that's your first signal that you have microglial private
And you have to start addressing it as early as possible because that's what leads to
microglial private leads to
chronic inflammation of the brain leads to
Which then can lead to antibody production of neural tissue
Which is you know can lead to all sorts of brain decline
And certainly
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's disease are on the top of that list for somebody who's over 60 years old
If you don't want to you know
start treating and
Early onset dementia when you start noticing the dementia signs
You're when you want to start treating it is when you start noticing the peripheral signs of
um
You know anxiety depression. I just don't have to drive ahead anymore
Running that those types of tests that we talked about before the different antibodies tests especially the
Cyrex array 7x which is the neuronal antibody tests can really save a person's life
Um, it may not prevent the person from getting dementia
But it can you know if you treat it right and you do the action steps and the person is willing to be committed to some of the action steps that I lay out for them
You can push the dementia out 10 years and that makes a big difference
If you've never experienced a loved one and your family go through
dementia
um
You you may be little the issue
Um, it is a big issue with that person when you lose your mind and you lose your ability to really think
Um, I don't think that you know the twitches in his hands and feet unless they're acute if this has been going on a long time
I don't think that they're probably not related to
Something like brim cancer
Um, though and it can be an issue you have to consider that if you have acute neurological issues like um, you know
Most times brain cancers diagnosed by you know person happy
A seizure or something like that so they have an acute neurological issue that they're never had experience of but if you have you know chronic
You know issues with twitching the hands and feet you start thinking in flammatory responses
So inflammation in neural tissue could certainly cause that upper motor to run
Issues with uh in the prefrontal cortex in the more frontal motor cortex. What controls that function
And uh inflammation in the cerebellum so the cerebellum
Smoothes out all your motor function motor function. We need that I'm gonna raise my hand
That's a motor function and contracting a muscle
But I'm contracting a muscle and I have you know trebers like this
That's typically a cerebellar function idiot look at cerebellar antibodies that cerebellum is the back part of the brain
That smooths that all out
so um
Investigating that finding out what is a cause is most important thing and I think well how that until the day I die
Is that you don't just treat a symptom you figure out what the symptom is trying to tell you
It's trying to scream me to you your body is telling you something
You need to learn to how to listen to the body and find a doctor that will listen to that and dignify in some of these causes